hey reject nation Greg Alba here Shawn
we are hosting a live event our very
first real rejects live event or it's
gonna be all sorts of fun meet and greet
included for only a thousand dollars you
can get a tick now it's gonna be take it
alone cheaper than that Saturday July
7th at 6 o'clock p.m. at arena Sena
lounge on Sunset Boulevard and what this
event is gonna be it's real rejects film
therapy and I don't know if you guys
have seen on the mist movies channel
mist movies being Brianne Chandler she
does a segment called film therapy and
on there she's had many guests like
Hector Navarro
Sasha pearl raver John Roca Jeremy Jones
Jen ster jure William Viviani Emma 5:00
Kristian harloff Clark Wolfe and Scott
Nance a whole bunch more people included
and John and I have been on there
ourselves easily the biggest easily the
biggest one of them all that's why we
listed everyone because we wanted to
segue into us being more popular than
all of that they look best for life and
how the film therapy works is Brianna
asked us a series of personal questions
that somehow linked to our personal
lives like her most common questions
tend to be what is a film that inspires
you what is a film or a scene that
triggers a memory for you that could be
perhaps painful or maybe even happy and
another common question is what is a
film that helps you through difficult
times those tend to be the top three
questions she asks she's gonna have more
for us to do on brands it's just a live
stream which answers the questions and
Apple will do for our since it's gonna
be at a movie theater as after we're
answering the questions course are gonna
be referencing films will screen a clip
at the movie theater from the movie we
are talking about so you get to see a
lot of random collections of different
scenes on the big screen at arena cinta
lounge and we'll be doing commentary
over it as the clip is playing - of
course Briana Chandler will be there her
partner co-host and person who is
helping coordinate the event for us
Stacy Howard will be there as well I
don't know who else part of the reject
nation family will be there of regular
guests that come on this channel but if
there are real friends at least one of
them will show up we want this to be a
private intimate event the reason we
like this theater so much for that is
there's only 50 seats available to
attend here right now there's only a few
seats that have been sold but we want to
pack this with as many people as we can
if even only 10 people show up that'd be
cool all the more intimate man all the
more intimate it's gonna be an orgy of
sorts and if you buy a ticket that money
will go to murdering that guy blowing
leaves outside surprisingly expensive to
have somebody killed it's way more money
than we thought even though Kristian
harloff has done it many times I don't
know how we can't afford it yet but now
all the money will be going to allowing
us to have the theater space that day it
was our very first live event this has
been kind of a dream sort of in the
background for the both of us for a
while I mean we both are big fans of
revival house cinema and we also came up
doing live comedy and stuff like that
and the idea of doing like a
meet-and-greet or something on a more
personal level something a little bit
more live for lack of a better word has
something yet has just been a dream of
ours for a long time and so we're really
grateful to the arena because they've
been doing a great job showcasing indie
movies and interesting things over the
years they just moved into a new space
and so this seemed like the perfect way
to sort of grow and expand and get to
know you guys a little bit better in the
process we're hoping to make this sort
of an interactive thing yeah I mean you
know we're gonna kind of guide the show
and brands gonna help us with that but
part of the goals that we can all kind
of join together and partake in the love
and celebration of cinema because I
think movies mean a lot to a lot of us
not just me and Greg but you know you
guys too and everyone's got a movie
that's helped them through tough times
and we thought that doing it this way
instead of just showing a movie we like
which is cool which is great which we
might do in the future if this becomes a
periodic thing but we wanted to do
something that was a bit more specific
and a bit more interactive so that's
basically the the idea behind this and
we're hoping that you guys will come out
and have a good time with yeah we are
gonna film it we're gonna edit it down
so we're not gonna put the entire event
on camera you know we're also gonna open
it up to a Q&A from whoever attends so
you could be featured in a real rejects
video as well July 7th that is a
Saturday at 6 p.m. and yes we will be
hanging out with all you guys who attend
you can get your tickets at arena screen
com there's a specific link in the
description box as well as a pin comment
for you guys to come out hang out with
us and enjoy in the fun festivities that
we're gonna be having trust me it's
gonna be event worth doing gonna be a
total blast and if you're into indie
cinema I mean not been to the arena
cinemas you're gonna have a new place to
go check out the later
we don't need to promote the feeder you
know what we don't just us or there
we're they're lucky to dis yeah we're
gonna move to AMC Burbank 16 the IMAX
that would be an overwhelming day of
yeah hundred thousand dollars per seat
and also if you get tickets make sure to
send us a tweet so we can know that you
are definitely coming to the event
looking forward to meeting you guys
hopefully as many of you can come as
possible and if you don't live in
California quit being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and come out here anyway take a
train a bus a plane so many options and
the first 10 people to get a ticket will
get baptized by Greg and John yes we
will have holy water on-site as well as
a kids swimming pool so subscribe bye
bye